my boys Benvenuti ablo espagnol Porque
che esso è su un gameplay in spagnolo No
perché residenti vol 4 signori è mio
padre ed è un gioco ambientato in Spagna
Madonna che sto giocando al remake di
sta roba Sono troppo contento allora ho
detto che non avrei fatto più Gameplay
Meno male nella vita quando prendo una
decisione è sempre quella non potevano
fare residenti vol 4 ok ho fatto tutti i
Resident Evil quasi tutti sul canale
Let's go my boys con questa demo donna
sono troppo Cioè Ragazzi io non so
spiegarmi cosa significhi per me un una
roba del genere 30 settembre 1998 mio
padre una data che non dimentico
quando il poliziotto è in memory quella
notte era con City fu Rasa al suolo Eh
me lo ricordo
anche voi mi sa Io sono sopravvissuto ma
per molti altri non è stato così
mi è stato chiesto di unirmi a un
programma governativo Top Secret
non che avessi scelta
Minchia
ce la faccio quelle missioni mi hanno
quasi ucciso
ma almeno mi hanno aiutato a non pensare
se potessi scordare quella notte
quel dolore anche solo per un secondo
stavolta può essere diverso
[Musica]
deve esserlo
io in macchina fino ai 25 anni perché
non avevo la patente per uguale a
posizione sempre quella era bella per
Lion Madonna come lo adoro io lui sono
passati 6 anni da quando Lyon è Scary è
sopravvissuto all'incidente di raccon
City un disastro biologico senza
precedenti causato dall'ambra
Corporation dopo essersi distinto ma
gente speciale negli States viene
affidato l'incarico di localizzare la
figlia del Presidente che è stata rapita
questa qua non è buona a fare un cazzo
ma lo capirete più avanti la ricerca lo
porta in un villaggio europeo l'ultimo
posto in cui la ragazza è stata a vista”
lo attendono qua e io purtroppo che li
so ve lo confermo inizia
Ah così ok stavo in macchina prima stavo
in macchina Dov'è la macchina Eccola qua
guidavo io quindi la macchina si è
schiantata Perfetto allora mi fa strano
c'ho la pistola sì e qua ce l'ho il
taschino e tira fuori Vabbè Eh non la
usiamo c'è uno scarpone prendi questo mi
fa stranissimo Ragazzi mi fa troppo
strano perché lo conosco bene residenti
col 4 quindi mi fa strano giocarlo così
Madonna lì ho il mio padre Mio padre
sono contenti Non lo so ragazzi Sono
troppo contento di giocare sta roba
Eccola qua una porta semiaperta il
Resident Evil non è mai un buon inizio
però entriamo
ti ho detto di mangiar solo le
crocchette e poi succede questo Mamma
mia oh
[Applauso]
è normale non sono vegani qua a quanto
pare Cioè non il veganesimo non è ancora
popolare A covacciati sì perfetto Bello
pieno di sangue
[Applauso]
Oh finalmente siamo arrivati nella casa
in Crime No perché risentivo quattro
parti subito Ragazzi ma il coltello ce
l'ho
Vabbè non mi fa usare le armi per adesso
Ma chi se ne frega Hello
cioè nisciun Comunque io entro in casa
abbandonate dal 2012 e non mi è mai
andata bene Però continuo a farlo perché
giustamente
ho già chiesto io Lyon una risposta in
su qua c'è Eh me lo ricordo io cosa c'è
c'è lo zio Ah non in questa porta però
Oh bello No dai che lo appendo in camera
cos'è
se a serca è giusto che vuol dire sì
Cerca il No non c'entra un cazzo Il
giudizio universale dice Io lo so lo
spagnolo Eh lo so perfettamente a quanto
pare bene Meno male che basta mettere la
s alla fine Uh cos'è Ah stata cucina
qualcosa
Bono sicuramente sarà un piatto Gourmet
questo 5 stelle Michelin posto Eh qua
c'è una porta
Tremors contigo estremo sporche vivi
contigo questa scontico Madonna tutte le
scritte sono Ah c'hai la serratura che è
chiuso va bene Oh ciao qua dentro eh che
me lo ricordo ce sta lo zio
sta mio zio qua uno che somigliava più o
meno a nonno Chuck quanto mi ricordo Poi
non so se è uguale qua
Eccolo e vedi qua è uguale è identico
proprio lui non ti cacchio sta cosa non
l'ho mai capita Sì sì bravo Chiediglielo
sicuramente ti risponde che il primo non
ti caga il primo Zombie non ti cagano
per esempio qua non ho capito perché
fino a che
anche lui sa le canzoni di Enrique
Iglesias Chissà cosa sta cucinando un
Non vedo l'ora di assaggiare
che è
Mario Fernandez Castagno eh non è lui mi
sa eh Occhio
hai spezzato tutto anche la famiglia
chiave del seminterrato ho trovata
eccolavamo è questa ce l'abbiamo fai
vedere che stavi cucinando di buono
dado Star questo eh Lo vedo là Beh io
posso Ah adesso tirata fuori la pistola
attenzione Eccola posso anche usare il
coltello
però non posso cucinare quello quello lo
raggiungeranno più avanti l'erbetta la
posso prendere No no per quello che
pensate voi eh Perché Uh cos'è qua Ah
carne fresca non ci non sono vegani Qua
abbiamo già detto sta cosa proiettili
qualcosa del genere No perché mi preparo
A dopo perché so cosa succede dopo Cos'è
questo Ah quello di prima Beh grazie È
stato piacere Carlo Come cazzo ti chiami
la devo usare la chiave no
Eccola belli per adesso raga è
fighissima Vabbè ma non lo sapevamo se
come gli altri remake ci sta
Vabbè allegro almeno Sempre allegro eh
Mi infilo in cantine da sempre sono
abituato ma il Resident Evil mai perché
lì è sempre qua è sempre una sorpresa
Sono scaramantici Beh Meno male vedo gli
ha portato bene comunque
eh scusate non mi è venuto così perché
scrivete sulle cose ma che problema Ma
che schifo e questo non è un tacchino a
quanto pare Ho già sprecato un
proiettile per nulla tra l'altro Vabbè
comunque è l'ombra minchia
tensione che qua non voglio sorprese
permesso
che hai visto Ehi lui è Carlo Carlo
Castagno come cazzo si chiama Fernandez
bello Carlo Eh ti vedo ti trovo bene
ti dicevo
Qual è la
situazione
e gli stanno facendo ascoltare canzoni
di Enrique Iglesias a manetta Vabbè
vediamo se riusciamo ad andare avanti
cos'è fuggi dalla caccia dalla casa del
cacciatore
Ok mires ecco adesso mi fanno spunta uno
nel seminterrato Io lo so eh mi respira
per forza Anzi ci sono proiettili quando
son fissato Scusatemi ma residentivol
non bastano mai eh chi è stato mia nonna
chi è
[Applauso]
non è morto e ho sparato 60 colpi
sebbene No è morto Vabbè Eh niente mi ha
colpito non moriva son due colpi
10 ne avevo ne ho sprecati già 8 Cioè è
incredibile 8 colpi Poi sento gente
ragazzi M'è arrivata altra gente Madonna
che palle oh oh
che cazzo scusi
Ah è qua
un forestiero No un monastero cos'è che
ha detto oh oh
una Ciocchi de Mood Madonna che botta
l'ho scassato il coccige è un minimo che
è questo C'è voluto un colpo gli altri
62 No ma il calcio di Allora il calcio
di Lione è più forte di proiettile
ragazzi bisogna sfruttarlo o un solo
colpo Però adesso questo è un problema
eh Sono Proietti ragazzi proiettili
proiettili
Ok
bene vamos È andata malissimo però va
bene
che
la tizia che devo trovare la figlia del
Presidente
nido
qui quando uno
villaggio
come pensavamo quindi ben fatto
mi serve la posizione di un lago forse
si trova lì ricevuto Mi metto alla
ricerca Fai presto
La gente qui è impazzita
la mia scorta
devo andare a dopo ragazzi non ho
proiettili non ho proiettili ha velato
non ho proiettili non ce li ho permesso
Minchia ti adoro Meno male mi ha salvato
il culo lì o nella cinematica non avevo
proiettili
ha pelato non c'ho non potevo farti
fuori non ho preso quei calci
tanto la palla ce l'hai in testa andiamo
avanti
si può
bene
grandissimo dici diverso il lago Non
vedo l'ora Minchia ho un colpo c'ho No
ragazzi sono morto
che devo fa' di qua che promette bene
dai fino qua tutto bene tranne per i
colpi però ve l'ho detto ragazzi i colpi
sto gioco sono una roba incredibile
ma ti devo far fuori Mi fai male che è
va bene il dubbio cazzo ne so io che mi
ha dato polveri da sparo hai visto che
che serve I Corvi hanno la polvere da
sparo non so come Però vabbè Uh
ci sono ci sono Grazie a Cristo Meno
male No ragazzi ero morto
ce n'è un altro i mesi di mesi
no la polvere da sparo Vabbè Quanto cosa
ma c'è il menù Io Eccolo Allora
munizioni pistola 5 poteri a sparo e un
e non lo posso fare ragazzi non ce l'ho
Non ho abbastanza risorse Va beh
documenti
Ah ecco e ho una cura una sola va bene
Complimenti Io non per essere partito
attrezzato Salviamo la partita prima che
a noi è una demo giustamente non mi fa
salva' giustamente Eh allora andiamo
avanti Speriamo di non morire sento
gente attenzione che qua
No basta punizioni per i corvi
tanto un casino
[Applauso]
c'è un cane non lupo sto sognando ti
sento versi non so se è normale
amore oh Bella lì ragazzi coi calci oh
in questo sito imboscati nei cespugli
Porca [__] che mira che c'ho Oh
Dais bellissimo
Ok
Ali devi pure far fuori col coltello che
sennò si alzano va bene il primo ho
sprecato otto proiettili con questi me
la sto calvando eh teoricamente
Oh [__] Ma che cazzo è mi sono
pure cagato addosso Mi sono fatto male
merda eh dimmelo Mi fai vedere la vita
ah non me l'ha tolta quella me l'ha
tolta il tipo di prima quindi a posto va
bene
Oh
lo schivato Non so come mai non ho
capito cosa hai detto ma ti sparo in
bocca Ok
Minchia
Eh mi sa che il naso te lo rifaccio Ezio
Ah posso anche usare il coltello io non
è che devo usare per forza i proiettili
pezze Camon
ho trovato altri proiettili non so dove
ma li ho presi Cos'è questo
grand'assorbente va bene
vai per adesso è ok lo so che c'ho
Ok una cura è una granata Store dentro
va bene ragazzi Tra poco dovrebbe
arrivare il punto in Criminal Madonna
cos'è Ah una porta normale posso aprire
Yes
tra un po' arriviamo al punto top
proprio quello che è top al mondo Non
vedo l'ora Tra l'altro Eccolo qua ecco
Infatti Con un detto picchia già ve lo
dico siamo nella cacca piena ma fa
niente
Eccoci
a quello che quello è il poliziotto di
prima
era il poliziotto vabbè
c'è un gallo guardiamo il gallo Okay
è morto posso va bene tutta sta gente me
la devo tirare io addosso come se niente
c'è qualcosa Eh poi ci devo arrivare
dall'altra parte e mi devo andare già io
posso andare a accovacciato che mi
vedono Vabbè pieno C'è pure una vecchia
de merda che devo fa piano piano piano
piano piano piano
come faccio
Stai zitto che minchia tiri tutti
non ho visto eh attenzione
Ah cos'è
lo so Ah mi fa arrampicare Ah se c'ho
qualche compagno mi fa arrampicare non
c'ho nessuno ok l'erbetta Meno male
Yes posso combinare le cose credo di sì
Yes raga Tutto ok Tutto come gli altri
sentivo tutto giusto posso entrare nelle
porte senza farmi vedere per forza
c'è una zia posso provare a farla fuori
da dietro tipo Assassin's Creed vediamo
Ah zia
Sì Madonna che culo benissimo
Eccole qua le risorse Meno male allora
adesso posso combinare teoricamente
anche munizioni del fucile cioè si
fucile se ci fosse se ci fosse Allora
fammi Innanzitutto
ricaricare l'arma Cioè mi dice allora
già adesso sono abbastanza messo Non
bene di colpi ma meglio di prima
minchia di qua posso entrare lo Speriamo
non attiri nessuno Bravo complimenti non
se n'è accorto nessuno non so come non
se n'è accorto nessuno
pure pure la chiave Oh ma stavi se ne
sono accorti Salve No ho trovato aperto
sono entrato Porca [__] combatti Eh
grazie al cazzo
questo Cos'è che me ne faccio dei
pesetas Ah il presidente servono per
comprare le cose Dal mercante che fa
tipo web con non so avete mai visto sto
tizio il mio personaggio preferito tra
l'altro anche lui mio padre ok E mi sa
che si sono allarmati tutti raga eh
poi adesso sono un cazzo vuoi Ma è
ancora vivo merda eh
gli ho spaccato il naso in compenso va
bene
merdaccia che male
non ho chat fuori o non muore Oh minchia
che boh la Combo cioss cazzo so Goku
bene bene bene bene bene bene bene bene
bene C'è qualcuno qua
c'è qualcosa per terra
Eh vabbè ragazzi minchia
Minchia che male
morite morite Mori
Ahia [__] Che male sono morto No
quasi però
Ok mi ha fatto malissimo forse è meglio
che mi levo dal cazzo eh non so Ok mi
hanno allarmato tutti Vabbè Eh no quanta
gente sta arrivando ragazzi eh no son
troppi ma cazzo siete
perfetto vai vai vai vai vai
aspetta Innanzitutto faccio fuori due e
No vabbè ma minchia Dai che mira che
c'ho prendo sempre quello sbagliato No
non volevo fare questo volevo fare
un'altra cosa volevo far cadere il fuoco
Ecco ma arriva quello che penso io eh
Ciao [__] Salve sono quello che fa
casino nei villaggi
Minchia che brutto Oh Madonna ha fatto
molto più brutto di quello che di quello
originale Madonna io volevo far cadere
qua il fuoco che si può fare Ecco qua ho
sentito poco no ho dato fuoco solo alla
mucca io lo vado a fuoco a tutti Vabbè
Scherzavo dai fuoco a qualcuno mentre
passi Povera mucca non volevo fare cioè
è l'unica l'unica persona cioè non è una
persona non so se lo sapete sono animali
le mucche Cazzo mica che non volevo
colpire dalla mucca cazzo è la cosa
giusta da dire in questo caso eh posso
lanciare una stordente ma giusto perché
Salve micia in testa
l'ho colpito in faccia è stato orribile
Eh vabbè ma lui non gli fa niente
ragazzi Aiuto dove vado sono andato via
dove sta andando Oh
No ma non lo faccio fuori neanche con
tutti i proiettili che c'ho Ragazzi ve
lo dico già eh no no muoio muoio son
morto uh
che cane Vabbè sono morto Raga non so
che non so che fa o passo e prego che
non mi colpisca
è andata male Però vabbè mai andare nei
vicoli ciechi quando soprattutto se non
sapete se c'è un'uscita quando c'è uno
con la motosega Allora quello è un
dettaglio quello è un dettaglio Ah me lo
fa rifa tutto E allora me ne fotto la
zia
Allora proviamo andare subito dalla
mucca perché vedo che almeno passano
tutti di qua teoricamente ce la dovrei
fare vediamo
sono state passate la strada
yeah adesso io ho seccati tutti
teoricamente Eccoli lì Questo vuole
allora sono partito meglio eh
sono partito meglio
teoricamente Madonna io ho scassato
tutti gli stinchi natanti vediamo se
riesco a riprendere i colpi di prima
Vabbè ma tanto se faccio porca [__] Ma
quanto siete raga e 2000 gli ho dato
fuoco eh
Madonna ragazzi
Ecco perfetto Vabbè comunque molto
meglio di prima ragazzi il fuoco ha
fatto la sua parte non so da dove arrivi
sto tizio perché non ho e dalla porta
dove sono entrato io che non ho ben
presente
il punto proprio Ok setta spezzettas
giornos non ho non ho colpi Ahia [__]
pure i polli
Sì ho dato 2.000 persone chi sono questi
chi sono chi chi chi so chi è stage Chi
è veramente guarda guarda guarda ho
fatto un casino ok
perfetto via via via via via via via via
via via via via Dietro Minchia allora
teniamoci una via di fuga una porca
[__]
giorno mi scusi non volevo rompe le
palle Devo solo uscire voglio solo
uscire non si può uscire va bene va bene
va bene non esco
E vabbè sono morto di nuovo Non lo so
Allora l'unica cosa che c'è una grande
frammentazione Allora posso provare a
fare una cosa ma non garantisco niente
dai proviamoci
No così cazzo L'unica cosa che devo fare
Bravo bravo via fuori Ce l'ho fatta Che
culo Ah proviamo con la granata al tizio
Daje Daje Pam Mica sono morto così è
morto dai l'ho steccato ancora vivo
come faccio che succede la campana
[Musica]
avevo fatto una provata Dai minchia
adesso che stavo vincendo Ecco che
è successo
niente la campana è suonata non mancato
più
servir a chi
mi ha risposto
bellissimo Vabbè
grazie alla campa Mamma mia
sono andato bene la seconda volta meno
male che avevo appena detto che giocavo
bene e poi sono morto
[Musica]
Chiudi bravissimo Chiudi chiudi chiudi
che non ne voglio sapere Madonna ragazzi
Ma chi è questo gioco mette ansia
comunque a quanto pare
[Musica]
Madonna che casino che ho fatto
Ma dove stanno andando ma che cazzo ne
so ma chi se ne frega cioè
bellissimo raga bellissimo è durata poco
che peccato e durata poco mi è piaciuta
tantissimo
Madonna ragazzi non vedo l'ora che
scherzo già non vedo l'ora raga
bellissimo
21 minuti
3.850 a pezzettas Vabbè ragazzi Questo è
Resident Evil questa era la demo uscirà
tra una decina di giorni più o meno
ovviamente vi porterò il gameplay
completo Spero che vi piacerà perché a
me sicuramente piacerà perché è un gioco
della Madonna Secondo me Speriamo che il
remake tenga testa all'originale Insomma
vi aspetto per seguirlo qua sul canale
tutti quanti insieme Io spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto ragazzi come al
solito argomento e mi piace anche per i
social che come mi hai aiutato
tantissimo iscrivetevi al canale Se non
siete ancora iscritti e noi come al
solito ci vediamo alla prossima video
bella ragazzi